>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC
>> And, I have the honor
today of introducing Mem Fox.
[ Applause ]
>> Chances are if you have a child,
as I do, you've read a Mem Fox book.
This prolific Australian
writer is the author of more
than 35 picture books for children,
including some favorites
in my own household.
Ten Little Fingers and Ten
Little Toes, Koala Lu
and the very effective
Time for Bed.
Her first book Possum Magic,
the tale of two possums in search
of food that will make
the other visible again,
she has said was rejected multiple
times before it became the huge best
seller internationally that it is.
Her most recent book,
Lets Count Goats,
illustrated by Jan Thomas is
a typical Mem Fix masterpiece.
It is a subtle lesson that's told by
lovable animals in very witty verse.
Mem is a retired teacher and a
fierce literacy advocate who lives
in Adelaide, Australia and lists
among her likes world peace
and green paper clips.
[ Laughter ]
>> And her dislikes, which I'm
thankfully not wearing a brown
clothing, and untidiness and she
says that she enjoys sleeping
and I assume she also
enjoys writing,
but I will let her tell you
more about that herself.
[ Applause ]
>> Mem Fox: Hi, or as
I bet you're dieing
for me to say, "Good day[HC1]".
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: And I used to think that
Australians didn't say good day,
I thought it was just something that
Americans thought Australians said,
but I've been listening and we do.
We do say good day.
Once upon a time a very long
time ago, ladies and gentlemen,
boys and girls, a baby was born.
That baby was me.
[ Laughter ]
>> It's hard to imagine that
I was ever a baby but I was.
When I was six months old
my parents moved to Africa
and that's where I started school.
That's why I don't have
an Australian accent,
I have an English accent instead.
I'm so sorry that I don't
have an Australian accent,
I am ashamed of the fact that I
don't have an Australian accent.
My teacher, when I started school,
was a very frightening teacher.
An African man called
Mr. Lorvu [phonetic].
I was the only white
child in the school.
All my friends were Africans
and we learned to write sitting
under a big tree and we wrote
in the earth with our fingers.
That's how I learned to write, by
putting my finger in the earth.
He would do it in the air and
we would do it in the earth
and he would come around
and look at it
and if it wasn't good enough
we would sweep that bit aside
with the side of our hand and
we would do it again and then
of course we graduated later
to slates, which was fantastic
because in order to rub things out
on a slate you have to spit on it.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Well that was
how I learned to write.
I made a lot of friends at school
and they were all Africans.
I could have felt very different.
I didn't feel different, I didn't
notice the color of their skin,
I didn't notice the color of my skin
and I have remembered
that all my life.
Now days as soon as I say to
myself, by looking at somebody,
that person is different
from me I know
that I am making a very big mistake
because that person is not very
different from me in any way.
We are all like each other,
we are all human beings
and we are all the same.
When I grew up I remembered
my friends in my first class
and I wrote this book,
Who Ever You Are.
[ Applause ]
>> Mem Fox: My Mother was a
very difficult woman to please.
She was the sort of
woman who thought
that if I were praised I
would get above myself.
So she praised me very
rarely and especially
when I became enormously successful
with my very first book she thought
I was in mortal danger of some kind
or another, and her praise from
that time became even more sparse.
However with this book
she finished it and said,
without realizing what
she was doing,
this is my twenty second
book ladies and gentlemen,
twenty-two books I had to wait,
she said, "Oh, I love that book".
[ Applause ]
>> Mem Fox: So this book is rather
special to me for many reasons.
Whoever you are, children, are
there any children in the audience?
Can I see them?
I can see one or two.
You know this book is funny.
At the front they say
whoever you are,
inside they say whoever you
are, as if we could not remember
from one page turn to the next.
And amazingly, for the third time,
as if we were complete idiots,
they tell us, for the third time,
that this book is called
Whoever You Are.
Can you tell me what this
book is called people?
[ Laughter ]
>> Audience: Whoever you are.
>> Mem Fox: Thank you.
Oh, I just have to tell you
that I have a little grandson
who was born prematurely,
very, very prematurely.
It will be our only grandson, he's
now, his corrected age six months,
he was born on January the 4th.
And I have read him -- I read
him this book every single day
in the hospital.
I opened the door of the
humid crib, humidity crib,
and I read him this book.
So it is a very, very
special book to me.
I bet you're just wishing I would
get on and read it, you know.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Little one, whoever
you are, wherever you are,
there are little ones just
like you all over the world.
Their skin may be different
from yours
and their homes may be
different from yours.
Their schools may be
different from yours
and their lands may be
different from yours.
Their lives may be
different from yours
and their words may be
very different from yours
but inside their hearts are just
like yours, whoever they are,
wherever they are,
all over the world.
Their smiles are like yours
and they laugh just like you.
Their hurts are like yours and they
cry like you too, whoever they are,
wherever they are,
all over the world.
Little one when you are older
and when you are grown
you may be different
and they may be different
whoever you are, whoever they are
in this big wide world, but
remember this, joys are the same
and love is the same, pain is
the same and blood is the same,
hearts are the same and smiles are
just the same wherever they are,
wherever you are, wherever
we are all over the world.
[ Applause ]
>> Mem Fox: Whoever You
Are makes writing look easy.
It looks so easy and people read
a book like that and they say,
"You know I think I'll
write a picture book one day
when I have the time", as if
time were the only requirement.
As if talent had nothing
to do with it what so ever.
Now you look at that book and
you think, oh what's that,
she must of knocked
it up in an afternoon.
But of course I didn't, because
how many of you noticed that each
of the similar items in the book
has only one syllable, one syllable.
Their lives may be different,
their words may be different,
their schools may be different,
joys are the same, love is the same,
pain is the same, smiles
are the same.
They're all one syllable words.
And it drives you crazy, that
kind of detail drives you crazy
and I am one of the writers, the
few writers at this festival,
who writes as rarely as possible.
I think it adds up to about five
minutes a year because it is
so difficult to find
one syllable words.
Like a good man, they're
hard to find.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clapping ]
>> Mem Fox: Fortunately
I found the good man
and the syllables, so
I'm doing just fine.
I'm just doing fine.
My Mother was a very
wild Australian woman.
When we were in Africa she
could kill a snake with one blow
from a crow bar, which
she kept at the back door.
She brought me up to love Australia,
even though we didn't live there.
She sang me Australian songs.
She made me Australian cookies.
She told me about the
beaches and the people.
She read me stories about
Koalas and Kangaroos.
I was the most Australian
child ever in the world,
even though my home was in Africa.
When I was already grown up and
married, I came back to Australia
and pretty soon after
that we had our own child
and we called her Chloe and she
began to grow and to love books
and I was so shocked to find that
there were no Australian books
for my little Australian
kid to read.
I was outraged, people.
I was outraged.
Oh, yes she liked Beatrix Potter.
Oh yes she loved Dr. Seuss.
Oh, yes, they were all
fine, they were all fine,
but where was the Australian
book for my Australian child?
Surely, I said to myself, there must
be something for an Australian child
to read that wasn't
written in England
or America, but there wasn't much.
There wasn't enough.
I had to do it myself.
So I wrote a book, which
is now 27 years old,
it's called Possum Magic and
it is the best selling kid's book
in the world in Australia.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Those of you who know
anything about books and writing
and publishing will know that
for a book to be in hard back
for 27 years is something
unbelievable,
and Possum Magic is still
in hard back 27 years
after it was published.
So I'm pleased about it.
Not pleased enough to read it
to you, though, because I need
to hurry along with my talk.
I assure that you will have
some questions for me at the end
of this session, but
let me guess what some
of those questions might be.
One thing people always ask is,
how many books have you written?
So I will answer that
question by saying immediately
that I've written 36
books for children
and five books for grown-ups.
Now the last time I spoke to
anybody, about a month ago,
I had only written 35 books
and I've now written 36.
So, in the last month, in my
house, has come the new copies
of my latest book, which
are very, very exciting.
Particularly, as a first time
Grandmother, I have finally,
after 39 years of waiting,
been able to put For Theo
at the beginning of a book.
[ Applause ]
>> Mem Fox: Oh, its so exciting
people, it's so exciting.
You understand that, you know, for
me as a premature baby Grandmother
to have a six month old child
turning the pages every single time,
at six months is astonishing.
I mean I did not think
that kids could do that.
Flick, flick, flick.
It's sensational and he seemed
to like this the other
day when I read to him.
It came on the day that I left.
It came into my house on the day
that I left, which was Wednesday.
And it goes like this.
Now this may not go so
well, it may not go so well
because I've never read it
before, okay, except to him,
and that was just one to one.
This is my first big audience, and
you know you get to know your books
after awhile and you so them
really well and you know
when to turn the pages and so on.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: I'm going to
tell you the background
in how this story came to
be after I have read it.
This book is called Lets Count
Goats, Lets Count Goats.
Are we ready?
I suspect inside they say
lets count goats again.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Oh yes, they do.
>> Mem Fox: Because we're
idiots, we can't remember
from one page turn to the next.
Here we go.
I'm so sorry for the
people at the sides,
I will promise, I love you dearly.
I love you a lot.
Okay, I adore you but I'm going to
have difficulty because I've got
to read the book, probably
like this.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: And of course, you
know, you need to see the pictures
and you're so far away that it's
kind of pointless you being here.
Why don't you all go home?
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Oh dear are we ready?
Oh Lord okay.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Here we a see a
mountain goat frisking in the sun
and here we see a city
goat going for a run.
But can you count the seaside goats?
I think there's only one.
So you now have to imagine
what you're seeing on each page
because you can't see the
illustrations after this okay.
Here we see a drinking goat
and here a goat is eating,
but can you count the little
goats lost and loudly bleeding?
Here we see an airport
goat looking for her cases,
but can you count the pilot goats
with goggles on their faces?
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Here we see a show
of goat playing on the vase,
but can we count the rowdy
goats careering around in cars?
Here we -- oops -- what?
Oh, yes.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Here we see an over
goat and this one's going under,
but we can we count the crossing
goats terrified of thunder?
Is that five?
Five, we are at five.
Here we see the Sanford
goat playing with his toys,
but we can we count the trumpet
goats making all the noise?
You're counting aren't you?
Here we see a summer goat
with nothing left to mow and
but can we count the winter
goats huddled in the snow?
Seven? Here we see a fireman
goat climbing through the smoke
but can we count the rescued
goats trying not to choke?
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Here we see a
soccer goat roaring at the ref,
but can we count the cheering
goats who must be going deaf?
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Here we see --
oh my God, what are we up to?
Are we sure were up to nine?
Were you counting?
Hang on, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
oh my goodness, thank God, I
thought there was a mistake.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Now this page is scarey
because we should be
on ten, should we not?
I mean that's how counting goats go.
They go from one to ten.
We are gong from nine to
five, but there's a reason
for it, okay, don't panic.
Here we see the story goats
and all their shining eyes,
but can you count their pricked up
ears one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
You can? I'm not surprised.
[ Applause ]
>> Mem Fox: At the moment
my most popular book
in Australia is a book called
Where is the Green Sheep.
It is so popular that so many three
year olds get three copies of it
for their third birthday and they
already have a copy of their own,
so it doesn't go down well.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: It is so popular that
the illustrator and I decided
that we would like to do a companion
book for Where is the Green Sheep,
and I thought a counting
book would be a great idea.
However, my illustrator did
not like the text that I did,
so it could not be a companion
book because if it was going
to be a companion book
she had to like the text
and she didn't like the text.
And she was pretty
scarey about the text
and she said well you can write your
own book but I'm not illustrating
that one and she said
you can't use sheep,
I had called the book
counting sheep.
She said you can't use sheep
because that's a companion book
to green sheep and
you can't use color
because we've already got
Coloring Green Sheep .
And I wondered how many
words I could actually use
by the time I finished
this conversation.
Anyway, I rewrote the book,
called it Counting Goats
and that's how the
book came into being.
It came into being because of that.
But I do want to tell you
something about my grandchild.
I'm very pleased that I have
written Counting Goats
and that it's dedicated to him
because he will be able to count.
I was with my daughter a couple of
weeks ago, and she was holding him,
and she told me something
that had happened in 1998.
She said this happened in 1998.
And I said, "Oh that's
only eight years ago."
And she looked at me and said, "No.
No. It's 12 years ago.
2010 minus 1998 is
12, its 12 years ago."
And I said, "Well, you
know, I'm a writer.
I was never meant to do math,
it's not one of the things
that I have ever, ever
had the talent for.
I just can't do it, I've
never been able to do it.
I cannot subtract, I can't
add, I can't do anything.
I can't even work out a
percentage, really, on a calculator.
I mean it is appalling,
my math is appalling."
And she looked at this tiny child
in her arms and she said, "Oh Theo,
oh Theo what a genetic swamp
you have been born into."
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: So I'm very, very,
pleased that that book
has been written for him
so at least he will be able
to count even though I can't.
I'm going to finish by reading a
very rowdy book so that we finish
on a loud and happy note.
I was going to tell you a sad
story and then I thought no,
no we'll finish on a very happy note
because I want everybody to join in.
This book is called
Hattie and the Fox.
It's an old classic of mine.
Are there children in the
audience that I can see?
There are children, children,
children watch my finger children.
Hattie and the fox,
fox, or as you say fox.
Hattie and the Fox by Mem Fox.
How cool it that, fox twice
on the cover and probably,
knowing what we've seen before,
probably inside the book as well.
Indeed we have it,
Hattie and the Fox
by Mem Fox and this is how it goes.
Hattie was a big black hen.
One morning she looked up and said
goodness gracious me I can see a
nose in the bushes.
Good grief said the goose.
Well, well, said the pig.
Who cares said the sheep.
So what said the horse.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: What next said the cow?
And Hattie said goodness
gracious me I can see a nose
and two eyes in the bushes.
Good grief said the goose.
Well, well, said the pig.
Who cares said the sheep.
So what said the horse.
What next said the cow?
And Hattie said goodness gracious
me I can see a nose, two eyes
and two ears in the bushes.
Good grief said the goose.
Well, well, said the pig.
Who cares said the sheep.
So what said the horse.
And I would like you all to be the
cow, who seems not to have a brain
in her head, but she saves the
day in the end, and the cow says
in a very stupid sort of way.
What next said the cow?
Very good, very, very, good.
And Hattie said goodness gracious
me I can see a nose, two eyes
and two ears and two
legs in the bushes.
Good grief said the goose.
Well, well, said the pig.
Who cares said the sheep.
So what said the horse!
>> Audience: What next said the cow?
>> Mem Fox: And Hattie said goodness
gracious me I can see a nose,
two eyes, two ears, two legs
and a body in the bushes.
Good grief said the goose.
Well, well, said the pig.
Who cares said the sheep.
So what said the horse!
>> Audience: What next said the cow?
>> Mem Fox: And Hattie said goodness
gracious me I can see a nose,
two eyes, two ears, a
body, four legs and a tail
in the bushes, it's
a fox, it's a fox.
And she flew very quickly
into a nearby tree.
Oh no said the goose, dear me said
the pig, oh help said the sheep,
oh dear what [inaudible]
I've completely lost the plot
because it was all so terrible.
But the cow said "moo" so loudly
that the fox was frightened
and ran away and they were
all so surprised that none
of them said anything
for a very long time.
[ Applause ]
>> Mem Fox: And I think I have left
time for one question is that right?
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: One question.
I'll answer it with one
syllable words if I can.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mem Fox: Do we have a question?
Does anybody have a question?
Yes.
[ Inaudible audience question ]
>> Mem Fox: There's a book
called Guess What I was asked
about the illustrator and me,
which is typically of all my books,
I have nothing to do
with the illustrator.
I often don't meet the illustrator.
I don't know Jan Thomas
who did goats.
I hope to meet her because I love
the work, but I don't meet them.
I don't instruct them.
I would be furious as I was about
the green sheep, you know, book.
I don't like to be
told what I write.
As a writer, and because I have
know visual ability at all,
I never say to an illustrator
this is what I want,
because what I want is so
pedestrian, it's so low level,
it's so pathetic and geniuses,
you know produce things
that are so, so different.
The illustrations in guess what
are absolutely astonishing.
They're on a level with the
illustrations in The Goblin
and the Empty Chair by The
Dillon's, which is illustrated
by Leo and Diane Dillon,
just an amazing book.
So have we got time for one more?
No. Ten minutes.
Yes we have.
>> Could you read this book for me?
[ Background noise ]
>> Mem Fox: I cant.
I wish I could, I haven't got time.
Okay, I'm going to do it.
It takes two minutes.
[ Applause ]
>> Mem Fox: It takes two
minutes people, don't panic.
Once upon a time there
lived a pirate,
whose name was Boris Von Der Borch.
He was tough, all pirates are tough.
He was massive, all
pirates are massive.
He was greedy, no he wasn't.
He was scruffy, all
pirates are scruffy.
He was greedy, all
pirates are greedy.
He was fearless, all
pirates are fearless.
He was scarey, all
pirates are scary.
But when his parrots
died, he cried and cried.
All pirates cry, and so do I.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov [HC1]No
time needed before or after
[ Laughter ]
because it wasn't longer
than 5 seconds.
Page 1